[Musique]
bienvenue à tous on va parler d'histoire
de la médecine et d'histoire des
médecins avec mon invité Isabelle
coquillard bonjour
alors vous êtes vous êtes historienne
vous êtes docteur en histoire vous avez
soutenu votre thèse en 2018 je crois à
Nanterre c'est ça tout à fait
et sur le sur le thème corps autant des
lumières les docteurs région de la
Faculté de médecine de l'Université de
Paris au 18e siècle et de cette thèse
vous avez tiré un livre qui sort
actuellement aux éditions Audrey
champion des auditions Honoré Champion
font peut-être dire un mot c'est des
éditions beaucoup de publie beaucoup de
livres d'histoire qui sont aussi fallait
regarder si on passe l'agrégation des
irréviations et tous les programmes qui
sont publiés par les éditions de région
c'est ça tout à fait puis là c'était
dans la collection dirigée par Madame
jacquard qui elle-même a fait de
nombreux travaux en histoire de la
médecine donc j'étais particulièrement
qu'elle accepte en fait cette
publication et cette et cette relecture
aussi il y a beaucoup de différence
entre la thèse et le et le livre qui
sort oui alors il y a des notamment les
notes offres à paginales allégées il y a
des passages peut-être à moins à moins
développé il y a des choix à faire
effectivement alors on va revenir alors
déjà ce type les docteurs régent
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui ne
dit pas grand chose nous enfin
contemporain parce que on connaît les
médecins on connaît les professeurs de
médecine les docteurs régent alors c'est
quelque chose qui appartient à la
Faculté de Paris
ce sont des gens qui ont le doctorat de
médecine et qui sont habilités à la fois
à exercer et enseigner alors c'est toute
la particularité effectivement des
doctores région de la Faculté de
médecine de Paris donc à savoir comme
vous l'avez rappelé donc avoir ce
doctorat en médecine sachant que la
première étape est tout même voilà
aujourd'hui quand on fait des études
médecine il n'y a pas de licences en LED
il y a des distances en histoire il y a
des histoires dans les autres domaines
en médecine on parle plus glissant à
l'époque il y avait une licence de
médecine qui permettait d'exercer alors
tout à fait donc mais la licence est
propre au à la Faculté qu'il a délivre
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut exercer que
dans le ressort de la faculté qu'il a
délivre mais j'ai pu observer donc en
suivant ce corpus de docteur régent que
l'ensemble des licenciés de la Faculté
de médecine de Paris finalement passé
ensuite le doctorat et cette fameuse
Régence donc qui leur permet certes
d'enseigner à la Faculté mais également
d'avoir un rôle au sein de cette faculté
donc assembler au pardon participer aux
assemblées de médecins prendre des
décisions
accéder aussi aux fonctions de doyen
est-ce que est-ce que vous pourrez
comparer ça aux agrégés de médecine
d'aujourd'hui ou est-ce que c'est
différent
non il y a des similitudes effectivement
du fait de cette capacité à enseigner et
exercer il y a quelque chose qui m'a
surpris parce que c'est extrêmement
moderne quand même c'est que ils sont
contraints à ce qu'on appelle
l'autoformation c'est-à-dire ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la formation
permanente oui tout à fait alors ça on
le constate à travers l'évolution de
leur bibliothèque donc on peut observer
justement les publications les plus
récentes qui sont intégrées
qu'ils ont alors la bibliothèque est un
instrument de travail qu'il consulte
régulièrement lorsqu'il s'agit justement
de de rédiger des ordonnances de
conseiller différents remèdes donc cette
autoformation elle passe également par
des échanges entre eux donc entre
médecins notamment en France mais
également à l'étranger puisque les
docteurs régents sont membres de société
de médecine fort diverses effectivement
de l'ensemble de l'Europe également la
société londonienne qui est fort réputée
et il produisent aussi des comptes
rendus d'ouvrages il s'intéresse
également au topographie médicale
sachant que eux ne les rédigent pas mais
les lys et les valides au sein en fait
de la Société Royale de Médecine donc ça
après 1775 alors il faut peut-être dire
de quelle à quelle période s'étend votre
votre recherche ça part de 1706 1706
pourquoi parce qu'il y a un décret qui
organise un peu la médecine c'est ça
alors
c'est les guides Marly 1707
vous habitez dans les Yvelines
qui
donc qui est pris par le roi et qui
réorganise en fait les études médicales
alors quand je dis qu'il est réorganise
en fait le roi va calquer cette
organisation sur ce qui se faisait à la
Faculté de médecine de Paris
en rappelant un certain nombre
d'obligations au terme d'enseignement
mais également l'un des devoirs des
docteurs et Jean qui est de lutter
contre les charlatans les empiriques ou
les illégaux parce que les trois termes
le grand le grand ennemi c'est la
charlotte c'est ça parce que parce que
au fond avant ce décret voilà tout le
monde passe installer comme comme
docteur mais mais enfin goût comme
médecin mais mais on peut aller voir des
gens qui n'ont aucun diplôme c'est pas
très bien qui on va voir non c'est ça
alors la question du charlatanisme je
reprends un mot du 18e siècle et une
question est une question fort complexe
puisque les docteurs régent en fait sont
en proie à deux logiques donc la logique
corporative qui est de ne pas s'allier
avec ces charlatans et puis la logique
individuelle la logique professionnelle
qui est aussi de composer avec ses
charlatans sachant que le marché du soin
médical est extrêmement concurrentiel
donc pour plaire aux clients il va
falloir voilà s'adapter tout en
respectant et là ils doivrine de la
faculté et cette logique on va dire
commerciale pour se garantir la
clientèle donc voilà ça c'est des 1707
Marly qui organise donc la profession
médicale et puis la fin de votre étude
c'est 1789 alors on voit à peu près
pourquoi et ce qui va aboutir au fond en
1792 à la fin des corporations est-ce
que les médecins c'est une corporation
ah oui les médecins sont une corporation
effectivement qui ont des statues
statuts reconnus par le Parlement de
Paris et les médecins sont justement
très précautionneux et très attentif au
respect de ces statuts qui leur garantit
une certaine suprématie puisque le but
des docteurs régent c'est quand même de
rester au sommet de la hiérarchie
médicale sachant que nous avons donc les
médecins les chirurgiens et les
apothicaires puis il y a aussi une
concurrence avec la faculté de médecine
de Montpellier oui les deux grandes
facultés de médecine de l'époque c'est
Paris Montpellier c'est ça ça c'est ça
et on retrouve en fait cette concurrence
elle s'exprime aussi au niveau du choix
du premier médecin par le roi qui lui
tente justement de tempérer et de
valoriser à certains moments tel ou tel
faculté est-ce que d'ailleurs des des
grands noms de la médecine au 18e siècle
on va pas la pression que c'est on n'a
pas l'impression que c'est une période
de de découverte et énorme en matière
médicale mais peut-être que je me trompe
non non effectivement les découvertes
sont pas flagrantes en revanche il y a
beaucoup de de gestes pratiques alors
quand je dis geste c'est plutôt de
relation avec la clientèle qui se mette
en place tout ce qui va être système de
visite de consultation mais peut-être
qu'on y reviendra au cours de votre
entretien donc les types de
consultations
il y a également justement la promotion
de de nouveaux remèdes tout à l'heure
donc vous me demandiez à propos des
grands noms mais nous avons du dragon
fagon justement qui est à l'origine de
qui est médecin du roi qui est à
l'origine de l'édit de Marly qui
travaille avec Pontchartrain qui va
également
œuvrer au Jardin du Roi donc Jardin des
Plantes aujourd'hui Muséum d'histoire
naturelle de Paris il y a également four
croix pourquoi qui est un grand chimiste
qui va également avoir un rôle
extrêmement important auprès de Napoléon
Bonaparte puis premier
il y a alors Portal n'est pas docteur
régent mais à des liens avec avec ce
milieu également non les Jussieu pas
très loin d'ici
exactement donc qui sont également
docteur régent sachant que il faut dire
que dans votre livre d'ailleurs il y a
la liste à la fin vous avez étudié
combien
460 alors presque 460 en fait il y a 457
docteurs
alors sur toute la période et puis on en
a sept qui n'accepte pas à la Régence
alors pour diverses raisons parce qu'il
ne respecte pas la doctrine de la
faculté ou parce qu'ils n'ont pas
soutenu à temps leur leur Régence
puisqu'il y avait une
un temps déterminé pour le faire alors
je reviens à la période pour préciser
soit un peu clair 1707 c'est le Louis
XIV et 1789 c'est Louis XVI ça va ça va
être cette période de cette paix est-ce
que alors c'est pas c'est pas dans C'est
pas l'objet de votre chaîne mais est-ce
que beaucoup de médecins ont un rôle
dans la révolution enfin parce qu'on va
voir faut qu'ils sont c'est de la grande
bourgeoisie si vous pourrez dire en gros
mais est-ce qu'ils ont été des des ce
qui est beaucoup de médecins dans la
révolution
célèbre voilà donc Guillotin qui
participent justement aux réflexions de
l'Assemblée sur la santé
donc pourquoi j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure qui va devenir effectivement qui
va œuvrer en tout cas la mise en forme
de de l'université
la meuf vient me vient guilloter
pour revenir un ami il y a il y a une
doctrine il y a deux doctrines à la
doctrine hippocratique à l'époque pour
savoir à peu près c'est-à-dire
la théorie des quatre humeurs c'est ça
donc les quatre humeurs
notamment le sang la lymphe la bille
noire et la ville jaune et selon
Hippocrate l'état de bonne santé
correspond à il faut que tout ça vous
arrive bien et ils sont en parfait
équilibre et lorsque l'une des humeurs
prend le pas sur une autre ou au
contraire et moindre là le rôle du
médecin est de rétablir cet équilibre
d'accord et il y a une autre doctrine
qui est doctrine intro mécaniste c'est
ça c'est à dire que le corps est au fond
c'est une machine cette idée là
effectivement donc là il faut rétablir
le bon fonctionnement de cette machine
sachant que la santé on la définit le
silence des organes
alors revenons donc assez à ces médecins
raisons
donc on verra après que c'est
l'université de Paris c'est la Faculté
de Paris mais que il exerce pas tout ça
à Paris forcément je disais oui cette
c'est des gros bourgeois
oui c'est comme un bruit alors des gens
assez aisés alors oui ce sont des gens
assez aisés là on touche le domaine de
la bourgeoisie dite à talon
la bourgeoisie a talon ça aussi c'était
une expression qu'il faut peut-être
expliquer à talent parce qu'ils ont fait
des études au fond des études et parce
qu'ils exercent une activité qui n'est
pas dérangeante c'est à dire qui ne
s'est pas perdre l'état de noblesse
parce que certains d'entre eux sont
nobles et une bourgeoisie qui a certains
un certain naissances financières
puisque les études de médecine sont
coûteuses donc mes estimations
5000 livres
ça correspond à quoi ça me met le livre
aujourd'hui
300 livres le salaire journalier d'un
ouvrier c'est 20 seuls donc vincol c'est
c'est
la moitié d'une livre ah oui d'accord
c'est pas rien et alors est-ce qu'ils
viennent
l'extraction sociale au fond est-ce
qu'il est-ce qu'il y a une reproduction
sociale ou est-ce que c'est pas la
pression il y a il y en a qui viennent
de tous les milieux un peu alors c'est
une profession qui est très ouverte
alors évidemment il y a le prisme de ce
qui sont déjà
en contact donc avec des docteurs mais
qui ne sont pas forcément un des
docteurs de Paris on a également des
étudiants en médecine dont le père est
chirurgien quelques apothicaires et puis
quelques-uns viennent du domaine des
professions du droit parce que lia il y
a une
[Musique]
un lien culturel puisque les professions
du droit elles aussi sont des des
personnes qui fréquentent le livre qui
reçoivent des clients donc effectivement
il y a des docteurs régents en droit
tout à fait donc là il y a une
similitude très forte
et puis quelques marchands également
alors comme les études coûtent cher
et vous avez été beaucoup voir les actes
notariés pour pour votre travail
les questions du mariage elle est
essentielle non oui alors effectivement
la question du mariage est très
importante puisque j'ai pu observer
grâce donc à ces contrats de mariage en
travaillant sur la constitution des
dottes c'est à dire des apports au
mariage des futurs époux et épouses que
souvent la dot de l'épouse est utilisée
justement pour financer ses études
parisiennes parce que souvent il se
marie après avoir déjà obtenu en
doctorat dans une faculté de province
notamment Reims et orange ou il était on
va dire plus simple d'accéder donc à ce
à ce statut de docteur mais pour exercer
à Paris il faut absolument avoir le
diplôme parisien
et donc ça coûte cher et donc voilà on
se marie souvent on fait des mariages
pour avoir la note et qui permet de
faire ses études de s'installer aussi
parce que après
il y a des cabinets au fond alors il y a
ce que j'ai appelé dans le livre le
cabinet bibliothèque voilà donc c'est
une pièce de l'appartement qui est
complètement immobilisé
[Musique]
c'est pas et c'est dans dans le lieu où
on habite qui est une pièce réservée à
la médecine
du métier quoi voilà le domicile a une
double fonction domicile résidentielle
et puis domicile comme effectivement
lieu de l'activité donc dans ce cabinet
bibliothèque il y a un certain nombre de
meubles qui sont essentiels thématique
donc le bureau un certain nombre de
chaises également pour recevoir ses
clientèles et puis cette bibliothèque
qui encore une fois est un outil de
travail qui est consulté alors pas en
présence du du malade évidemment puisque
ça a créé quand même une voilà voilà du
temps mais effectivement par la suite
lorsqu'on va rédiger l'ordonnance oui
donc oui c'est très important est-ce que
c'est aussi une façon aussi de de
montrer un peu son savoir quand même
d'avoir une grande bibliothèque avec
beaucoup de livres il y a la question
effectivement de l'apparence et de la
mise en confiance effectivement du
malade donc il participe la bibliothèque
un certain nombre parfois d'oeuvres
d'art donc de tableaux qui vont
également mettre en confiance avec toute
une symbolique certains docteurs
essaient d'en imposer également avec des
collections alors les collections
minérales des collections d'insectes
également
donc pour pour montrer donc ce statut
scientifique on trouve également des
instrument tels que des baromètres
dans les 4
médecins régents que vous avez étudié il
y a que des hommes parce qu'il y a pas
de femmes qui exercent la médecine non
au 18e les femmes effectivement n'exerce
pas la médecine en revanche elles sont
présentes donc comme on l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure via effectivement le mariage
cela dit les femmes de docteur et Jean
ignorent tout de la pratique de leur
époux et ça on le lit en fait dans les
inventaires après décès où elle le
déclare au notaire en termes de pratique
donc on trouve quand même la présence de
femmes qui vont avoir le rôle de garde
malade voilà on pourrait dire c'est des
infirmières un peu oui ce sont des
plutôt des aides à domicile on va dire
plutôt on pourrait le comparer à des
aides à domicile effectivement
et donc elle elle suive en fait le
malade et puis elle essaye de lui faire
respecter l'ordonnance du médecin et
puis il ne faut pas oublier également
toutes les religieuses qui elles
interviennent dans le domaine
hospitalier est-ce qu'il y a une une
grande
relation enfin entre les médecins tout à
la parler de la consultation ce qui m'a
surpris c'est que on peut faire des
consultations à plusieurs par exemple
oui alors à la demande express du
patient qui va choisir les médecins qui
vont consulter ensemble donc l'idée
c'est de d'avoir une double expertise de
bénéficier aussi d'un double regard
alors souvent on associe un docteur plus
âgé avec un docteur plus jeune et puis
il y a des cas également alors un petit
peu quand même en marge ou le père va
effectivement consulter avec son fils
une façon de l'initier aussi à la
pratique
ça coûte combien une consultation alors
les consultations en moyenne coûte de
livres 15 ensuite le métro
effectivement qui est cher et je pense
que d'ailleurs on peut on peut en faire
un critère un marqueur social en fait un
marqueur de distinction sociale à cause
de ce prix après les médecins prennent
en compte un certain nombre d'éléments
pour fixer ce prix et puis on va avoir
toute une gamme alors je parle de prix
depuis tout à l'heure mais en fait ce
sont des honoraires puisqu'on rétribue
un service et ils vont inventer le
système de l'abonnement c'est à dire que
on paye voilà le patient donc choisi son
médecin donc l'abonnement varie de 200
livres par an à 300 livres en moyenne et
dans ce cas le médecin est tenu donc de
se déplacer à toute heure du jour et de
la nuit pour répondre aux sollicitations
du malade d'accord alors c'est cher mais
il y a aussi des systèmes par exemple
les médecins parois sont enfin il y a
des médecins qui s'adressent aux pauvres
enfin qui qui sont les beaux vont ne
sont pas totalement exclus du soin quoi
du soin médical non parce que les
médecins ont besoin en fait d'avoir une
une clientèle justement qui touche toute
la population et effectivement les
populations pauvres ne sont pas laissées
pour compte puisque les médecins de
paroisse donc sont engagés par la
paroisse et ce déplace en fait chez ses
pauvres et donne également des remèdes
alors là des remèdes effectivement qui
sont adaptés aux revenus de ces
populations et les docteurs régent sont
très intéressés par ces fonctions qui
leur permettent d'être reconnu par les
dames de charité qui font partie de la
notabilité de la paroisse donc ils se
font reconnaître ils se font voir
également de fait de cette circulation
et puis le médecin de paroisse reçoit
lui une rétribution qui est assurée au
contraire du client qui une sorte de
sécurité sociale on pourrait dire oui
bon ça permet en tout cas d'avoir un
revenu fixe en tout cas
soit payé que les gens les plus démunis
puissent avoir accès aux
tout à fait et puis également à
l'hôpital où les docteurs régent
également interviennent donc l'hôpital
au 18e était destiné uniquement aux
populations pauvres oui parce qu'il y a
pas il y a pas tellement cette
distinction qu'on fait aujourd'hui entre
la médecine de ville enfin la médecine
privée et puis la médecine hospitalière
alors au 18e si elle existe oui oui la
médecine privée donc c'est le malade qui
va directement solliciter le médecin et
puis à l'hôpital effectivement la
distinction ne se fait parce qu'on a
uniquement donc des populations pauvres
puis vous avez également les petits
hospices de paroisse
ils ont plutôt une clientèle privée oui
c'est ça
privée ensuite selon des choix de
carrière on peut enfin ils vivent
uniquement de cette pratique privée et
alors de fait ils vont développer tout
un système de journaux pour savoir quel
est le client combien de visites est
encore dû et puis il y en a qui vont se
diversifier donc via l'enseignement via
la pratique hospitalière par exemple et
puis diverses fonctions qui peuvent
exercer également dans les maisons
royales dans les ports au colonies alors
on va on va parler des colonies dans un
instant juste c'est vrai que alors il y
a aussi ce que ça m'a frappé ça je
savais pas que ça existait à l'époque il
y a une presse médicale
importante alors la presse médicale
effectivement est importante elle se
développe surtout à partir de 1750 pour
ce qui concerne les docteurs régent et
Vandermonde donc l'un d'entre eux voilà
va diriger le journal de médecine
chirurgie et pharmacie
vandermont
et effectivement
de faire également la promotion des
docteurs puisque les noms de circulent
il va faire les annonces de thèse qui
montre justement cette entrée dans la
corporation parce que finalement c'est
le seul élément qui qui marque cette
entrée
à côté des journaux de vandermont vont
se développer aussi des entreprises que
je qualifierais d'individuels donc telle
celle de barbe du bourg qui est docteur
et Jean qui lui développe également
cette presse alors professionnelle mais
qui s'adresse aussi aux clients et il
lance même un petit concours avec ses
avec ses lecteurs profanes donc ils ne
sont pas des des professionnels en leur
demandant de découvrir certaines plantes
qu'il va décrire donc il y a un jeu
comme ça de correspondance alors après
avoir si c'est un argument publicitaire
mais bon ça monte quelque chose
justement ça me fait un lien parce que
il y a alors évidemment il est docteur
régent qui ont plusieurs types de de de
d'exercice de métier
la publicité on n'aime pas ça y est il y
a par exemple il y en a un qui est qui
je crois qu'il fait nous contre les
maladies vénériennes
et les recentué alors
effectivement alors et puis il a fait de
façon assez particulière donc déjà le
remède c'est une audite anti-venerienne
donc le médecin en l'occurrence c'est
Gilbert de Préval
et il se met en scène il teste le
remettre sur lui il a des accointances
avec des milieux qui sont immoraux et la
faculté ne peut pas tolérer ça parce que
en faisant cela il remet en cause en
fait toute la bonne réputation du groupe
et là on retrouve cette importance de la
dimension corporative
un mot parce que malheureusement le
temps passe vite alors évidemment la
plupart enfin beaucoup des médecins
régents de l'Université de Paris exerce
à Paris mais pas forcément on retrouve
notamment en Bretagne on trouve et
surtout et dans les colonies les
médecins coloniaux du roi c'est ça
le médecin des colonies et le médecin du
roi ils ont aussi le titre de médecin
botaniste et effectivement
certains partent colonies alors pour
divorce raison pour refaire pour faire
fortune certains c'est par goût parce
que goût de la botanique donc la
médecine permet justement de ces
nouvelles explorations et là il faut se
faire bah un nouvel environnement une
nouvelle façon de faire
bon cela dit il continue à soigner
l'élite de de la colonie alors c'est ça
il ne soigne que les colons ils soignent
pas les les les les
locaux quoi
on peut dire au 18e siècle nos clients
encore des esclaves effectivement sur
les plantations non alors là c'est le
chirurgien de la plantation qui s'en
occupe
en fait
les gens qui sont là
pourquoi vous avez choisi ce sujet sur
le médecin ce sujet il est arrivé un
petit peu enfin c'est à la suite dans le
long cheminement puisque au départ moi
je travaillais sur les salons parisiens
d'accord et puis
voilà c'était en maîtrise et puis j'ai
pas pu continuer parce que le sujet a
été traité d'une main de maître voilà
par Antoine Lilti qui fait un magnifique
un magnifique ouvrage enfin bon et donc
monsieur Dumas m'avait proposé un
premier sujet sur les substituts du
procureur
et puis après
il m'avait proposé donc ce sujet sur les
substituts du procureur général du
Parlement de Paris qui d'emblée ne m'a
pas parlé en fait j'ai commencé quand
même à faire quelques recherches mais
c'était un domaine qui m'était vraiment
très très étranger
fort intéressant mais très étrangers et
puis les docteurs régents sont arrivés
et effectivement au départ j'ai eu moi
aussi cette ce premier réflexe de me
dire mais doctor et Jean Médecin quel
est le lien voilà exactement
et là et là l'almana Royal m'a beaucoup
aidé à comprendre justement de quoi il
retourne
le livre absolument passionnant
d'abord vous découvrez énormément de
choses comment au fond et puis alors il
y a aussi des sources que vous avez été
voir alors il y a le minutier central
des notaires notamment c'est quoi le
menuisier central des notaires alors
c'est aux Archives nationales de France
donc le site de paris donc le 40 ou l'on
trouve un ensemble d'actes notariés donc
notamment ces contrats de mariage les
inventeurs après décès qui ont été une
mine de renseignements effectivement sur
lspect social du groupe mais aussi sur
ses pratique professionnelle et c'est un
des apports du livre de montrer que
finalement
le premier réflexe serait de dire on
s'intéresse à la médecine on va chercher
des sources scientifiques bien là non
l'histoire sociale voilà nous aide à
comprendre
ils sont très importants effectivement
leur pratique et leur passé comme ça des
années des années dans les archives là
quand on reçoit à faire libre si je peux
dire on est comment on est très heureux
en fait parce qu'on a découvert plein de
choses et puis les archives c'est enfin
c'est voilà c'est c'est quelque chose
quoi quand vous ouvrez votre carton
là c'est comme si on trouvait un trésor
quoi exactement c'est il y a il y a un
bonheur là-dedans qui est un
descriptible la joie de trouver et puis
c'est un fil d'Ariane quand on a
commencé on veut savoir on peut
continuer on veut voilà on veut croiser
c'est un vrai bonheur les archives la
suite c'est quoi alors maintenant alors
la suite eh ben c'est de s'interroger
sur certains dossiers que j'ai pu
laisser un petit peu de côté justement
soit au cours de la thèse toujours sur
la médecine et puis de continuer à
travailler sur la bourgeoisie à talons
la bourgeoisie a talon c'est un mot que
j'ai appris grâce à une expression que
j'ai appris grâce à vous on peut
rappeler ce que c'est là-bas voilà
bourgeoisie qui a fait des études et qui
peut garder ses titres de noblesse on
peut travailler tout en étant donné quoi
c'est ça et puis il y a cette dimension
effectivement de rapport au savoir à la
diffusion de ce savoir et à son
utilisation merci beaucoup Isabelle
coquilla le titre du livre Corse au
temps des lumières les docteurs région
de la Faculté de médecine en université
de Paris au 18e siècle et c'est aux
éditions on aurait champion merci
infiniment merci monsieur
[Musique]